you
[Music]
it's a staff worth repeating across the
u.s. only 10 women chefs have been
awarded a Michelin star and Melissa
perello is one of them born in New
Jersey and raised in Houston she showed
an early interest in the kitchen at age
12 her mother came home to find her
deboning a leg of lamb she had her first
kitchen job in high school went on to
the Culinary Institute of America and
then to San Francisco where she opened
Frances and later Octavia both earned
prestigious Michelin stars and honor act
Octavia still holds now she's heading
south to LA her M Georgina opens this
summer at rody TLA the hot new retail
and dining project in the city's
downtown chef Marissa
Melissa Perello welcome to the dish
thank you so much can we start with
dessert this is one of our signature
dishes from our first restaurant
Francis's inspired by a dessert that my
grandmother used to make it's called a
lumberjack cake and well I'm a
lumberjack and I'm okay
coconut and it's today it's with a
little cream cheese ice cream what else
we also have a little pappardelle pasta
with bacon smoky bacon and parmesan
crema a spinach and grilled asparagus
salad with a lemony miso vinaigrette and
toasted shallots as well as a grilled
skirt steak with charred tomatoes and
eggplant
um it's finished with a little smoky or
chili which is a Turkish pepper and this
puppy and this is we're calling this a
smoky sipper looks very good yeah mezcal
ramen a little bit of bitters yeah I got
to go back to the deboning a leg of lamb
yes well are you serious
I am yeah I don't say I was kind of
strangely a very focused kid I always
always knew I wanted to go to culinary
school before I even started in high
school right and just got it got a start
on an early watching chefs on TV I did
yeah I grew up spending summer
in northern Texas with my grandparents
and there wasn't a lot to do so I found
myself watching a lot of cooking
programs on PBS this is Fran Frances was
your grandmother wait you call Frankie
yep but you named the restaurant after
your grandma I did both of my
restaurants so my third restaurant is
named after my my father's mother Mary
Georgina so sweet to the CIA
you knew always but I mean you're this
sort of East Coast girl you how do you
get to San Francisco I understand it was
based on a vacation oh yeah well I found
I went out to San Francisco to check out
the restaurant scene and fell in love
with a restaurant named aqua I started
working right after culinary school with
Chef Michael Mina who was one of my
mentors but just a chance conversation
led you to an externship absolutely very
very lucky you must have been convincing
[Laughter]
pleased to get to your star you ended up
being an executive chef by the age of 24
I did I did
it was very was a nerve-wracking
experience but it worked out in the long
run I guess yeah well what do you think
you look back on that time now and you
look how you are now what was the
biggest thing you took from that time
that you're using with you I think if
anything it's given me a lot of guidance
on how to how to lead my team now and
how to usher them and and give them
guidance and order how to lead their own
teams and give them give them an
empowerment to to drive the bus
themselves yeah this new experience in
downtown Los Angeles
I just I'm from Los Angeles are you and
I remember when downtown was pretty much
Skid Row and I'd have to say are there
did you have any apprehension about
moving in to the heart of an old city I
did I will say the first time I went to
go check out the restaurant space I was
a little bit nervous driving up but what
I find very unique about the row is you
you pull into the parking structure and
walk out and it's like a little oasis in
the middle of the city it's really
surprising
beautifully curated space lots of
amazing retail shops and soon to be a
ton of great restaurants you get nervous
every time you open a new restaurant
absolutely
well that wasn't so let me have you sign
the dish and as you do chef if you could
have this meal with anyone past or
present who would it be gosh I'd have to
say Michelle Obama I think it would be
an amazing experience I guess yeah we'd
like to stay for that one
chef Melissa perello thank you very much
Fletcher and for more on our chef and
the dish you can head to our website at
CBS this morning calm